it's time for the seventh innings
[Music]
hey did you see that mark oh
yeah come on pretzel let's go find some
mustard so i could eat you by myself
oh yeah come on kid sing along
let's go let's go team thanks but i
don't feel right singing the best fan
song when
i don't have a best fan to sing it with
huh okay jerry time to show the fans
what you got
let's go let's go yeah
gloria what do i do as long as they
think you're the mascot it'll be okay
so get out there and shake those
[Music]
[Applause]
opticals
[Music]
[Music]
my little yellow jacket
it doesn't matter who you root for
they're just hats
i know who my team is
wow jerry really up this game he's never
moved like that before
oh hey jerry wait a minute
if you're jerry who's dancing their
booty off over there
get that fake mascot oh oh
thank you get back here i'll keep them
[Music]
[Applause]
our star player is down
now our other star player's down what
could have caused such a string of bad
luck
it's obvious our good luck charm stopped
working or maybe he's a
bad luck charm we got to get him out of
the stadium before we load the guy
[Music]
why are those green fans chasing alex we
gotta save him
hey i thought you two weren't friends
anymore i know alex and sometimes act
like a buffoon but
he's my buffoon i'm gonna help you win
better rock put me in coach
take me off the
[Applause]
alex get bench there
marty i can't believe you came to rescue
me
you